play-doh it's your childhood in a yellow
plastic tub smooth and pliable moist but
not sticky taste salty smell sweet
what's inside this magic dome
it starts with flour and water warm
water breaks down starch in the flour
which makes the mixture thick and
viscous but as it cools water evaporates
ordinarily the starchy bits would cling
together and Harden not fun
that's where amylopectin comes in the
starch has hidey-holes for water
molecules that keep the dough moist and
pliable mineral or vegetable oil and a
white waxy substance called PG 1500 mono
stearate keep the texture smooth
playdough is actually about 10 percent
salt 10 times sold here than your
typical bread dough it binds up any free
water and it's the first thing you
notice if you take a bite right before
the bitterness hits
that's aluminum sulfate added to keep
the kiddos from seriously chowing down
it's also a preservative which along
with household cleaner borax prevents
mold and bacteria growth what about the
smell
that's sweet aroma that sends you
straight back to preschool vanilla is
Hasbro's only hint but the real formula
for the signature scent is guarded like
the recipe for coca-cola but we're fine
with a little mystery just don't get the
colors mixed up okay
want to see what's inside the subscribe
button go ahead and click it it's more
great wired stuff